στος επιχειρήσεις προσευκήπροσεκκήσαμε στην κύπρο λόγο του κρανικού να μελλαπεμελέμε και εμείς αλλά ήταν μια
συγκυρία την οποία κμα λεύτηκαι τη δεδομένι στημή της ηκυβέρνηση έχει και σεξακώςι οποιχειρίσεις ήταν
τοικόσικο δύο τετρακόες νομίζωυ το κοτρία και ακόσεις τοκτέσα ενώ είναι μια πτωτική πορ ή
ανάποτα ιακόες το τετρακόα κάμια πτωτη κοιτάση την οποία αντιλαμβάννομαι κυβέρνεση προσπαθεί νανα τη συλλάβει
να σταματήσει του την δηπτώσι άρα ι κατεύθησε σωστή κατεύθυση για νασωστη και δώ εδώ
είναι αυτό που λέμεν ότι ναι η πάει η οικονομία πκαλά λέει κατί το άα
μεφομος λέει κάτι το οποίο χτυπάμαν ωστα προηγούμενα που σας α με βλέει είναι περίοδος
όμως που ι αυπεραιτέρω ανάπτυξη μας θα υπάρχει ανάπτυξει τα εκόμενα χρόνια όπως λέει φυσικά
λόγό της καές τομεκαι ιπολιτικά ναι ένα άλλο θεμα ερχέται το ά με ευύκελέει ναι
είναι καιρός για απνδήεις περίπου του πούμε να πλά είναι καιός για απενήσεις χι σε
τίτομς και πάμε πίσω και ερχόμα στη και λέμε ακρίβια νθελούμε πλάμο για να κρια
και μόνο να αλούμε υπάρχει ακρίβια τι ενια κριβία η ακρύβια ξερίσαδη αρκετές φορές τουλάχει
στον εγώ εγκιτέετεσς πέτε παράγοντας οι οποία αγκίζουν τον καθένας το σπίτι του είναι α
τρόφημα είναι έργεια ιστέγαση η παιδία ηγεία είναι κομμάτια αυτής της αυτής της ακρίβιας και
μάλισταέχουν και πως ωστά το καθένα και όσο πιο χαμι χαμηλών ι στο δηματικό τρόμα
πάμε τόσο μεγαλώνυ τα ποσωστά διαθέσημου τα τόσο μικρίνι τοδι